comment bien choisir son lycée avec
l'assouplissement de la carte scolaire
les élèves ont la possibilité de se
diriger vers l'établissement qu'ils
souhaitent les lycées rivalisent d'idées
pour attirer de nouvelles recrues comme
au lycée Émilie de Breteuil de Montini
le Bretonneux qui propose depuis 2006 un
approfondissement de l'enseignement des
langues grâce aux sections européennes
des élèves qui en
terminal pour beaucoup ont un excellent
niveau et ça leur permet d'accéder à des
prépas d'accéder parfois aussi à sCIP à
sciencep Lille qui a un parcours
bilingue au baccalauréat 2012 le taux de
réussite était de 94 % au lycée Émilie
de Breteuil le 25e au niveau des
ivelines le 4e de l'agglomération
cinquantinoise derrière le lycée des
cartes de Montini un classement qui peut
déterminer le choix des futurs lycéens
ça me permet de d'avoir un repère en
fait de niveau de de de lycée c'est en
fonction de de la motivation des profs
de niveau au bac
et la condition de travail aussi si
c'est c'est un lycée dynamique
les élèves plus de chance à réussir i
j'ai regardé sur un peu t les lycées
pour comparer je vais essayer de prendre
option européenne anglais qu'il y a pas
dans mon lycée secteur cette année le
lycée Émilie de Breteuil a accueilli 980
élèves